I think for one spell comes from here
how are you real pleasure sounds my soul
will be so strong I can't do no real
pleasure hi Sarah
real pleasure
well that's [ __ ] platter and I'd like
your [ __ ] kicks man those are fresh
new chair everybody sat down lady like
the most ever biggest back analyte lady
ever I'm sure you're the coolest lady
really we've met when he started this
company when he started vaynermedia this
when we met back in [ __ ] sunshine
yeah but he lived in New York he's been
in LA though but he does the merchants
just the whole 400 thing and that's
raised with yg 24/7 I mean why do you
have never met foot we're so happy to
have you excited yeah man Congrats on
everything thank you bro it's real how's
it feel oh just something you just
sometimes though that you like take a
step away for a quick second be like
[ __ ] yes like yes that's what it is
right there's just no time I don't do it
either there's no time I kind of feel
like I always do it and never do it like
I'm conscious of it
you you guys but I never sit there and
be like oh my blessings like you know I
don't really have that conversation
oh no when I look like oh wait like what
search it happen to shoot like when I
guess me time I'm on the chorus line but
my surface luck tonight
yes yeah we did it
it was like we're taking everything we
do it bring it on it immediately better
ingredients better trying [ __ ] right
attentions about here yeah of course I
understand you know I'm sound like the
fashion brand but they get a lot of date
they influenced by the street a hundred
percent but it don't really know they
already can't vote no real Street
[ __ ] in the shoot just like
rappers and all that like yeah like we
make blow up bro you know what happened
right was the [ __ ] Internet became
the middleman there's nobody stopping
anybody from the street going from
street to the finish line that's what
happened
so like what everyone's like what's
happening simple be et and MTV and
Viacom didn't let the street get to a
certain level didn't have the
distribution you don't need them z100
doesn't control how 97 is in control
anything I mean they can they can help
but that's what people don't get it and
it's gonna happen more not less and then
they become you know it's very real and
I don't think people fully understand
theirs look I keep telling people like
there's nothing stopping anybody anymore
there's the perception of it there's the
way we think it is but like it's
laughable like the president media
companies it went from this to this to
this from this to the do you understand
that look at this you see that because
I'm a hundred percent right that's
what's up people don't get it this is
what's happening is not a teacher this
is yg I'm aware ain't it so that's so
smart you know what I mean it's just so
smart to have a brand that lives on
it's like really not t-shirts so I mean
yeah this is what you're like and stuff
that we're working here right now it's
like crazy so what's so what's the team
I know who you are
another creative direction of design for
the common brand they not were quite as
yours music stuff
artist I understand so you got thing
guys on the music front you're a partner
that way a service provider but you're a
partner in the other clothing brand so
you guys are really integrated thank you
guys hey tee it's somebody give me a tea
do you know about that
cool thank you so much it making you is
he cool and how about you management
Oh so it's new you guys knew each other
for a minute you guys knew each other
for a minute yeah makes sense of course
well no when I stood on stage and told
everybody they're full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
everybody was on see thought they were
special complaining about dumb [ __ ]
who's that yeah yep
he's gonna do understood got it artist
well I appreciate it
talk about man for everyone watching to
is just the whole stay dangerous you
know if you want to talk about it
explain it like whatever you want to say
about it but it's like reaching a
different Democrat know so so so so stay
dangerous concept of all you know I'm
saying it he came from the streets
you diced mango on fire I know that's
how we told them that's like getting
cultures but uh I'm just taking that and
I'm applying it because I'll really then
when you sit down and you think positive
life stay answers you know I'm saying
I'm so wait that's the way of living out
it's a mine salad beautiful monster it
maps to everything exactly like
knowledge is dangerous 100% and all that
nonsense was like I'm trying to spray
I'm trying to spread that out why like
that you see that as a positive right
that's how I see it because I'm aware of
it and I'm like that's the same [ __ ] I'm
saying just different words and
obviously different circumstances it's
just so interesting to watch that skill
set which is very foreign to most people
that you grew up with it's the same [ __ ]
it's just people don't get it it's also
basic those 80 year old white guys and
the big towers over there they're
playing that same game they're just
using that are just using different
weapons same [ __ ] two sides same you
know just people confused that high low
security my man my man my man my man my
man
anything and I'm telling you and I'm
telling you and I'm telling you and I'm
telling you you're hungry bro I hate a
TD if you call it ambition I understand
like it's not like you're drawn you know
you trying to make money my guy a DB
when it's ambition is exactly right I
love when people like she's on the
record she's got people she's gonna have
to answer to Rayna she's about to get
hurt she's nothing gonna text she's
about to get a text and a wig she's on
the record
but the other thing about stay dangers
are really respected by you is he you
speak your mind man like when you said
the dial Trump stuff or what do you like
see someone out of line or what you just
do whatever it's so respectable that's
the best SC were afraid Mike Mike that's
the best part of the advantage of what
he grew up with saying that should is
not scary compared to what he could like
that's kind of like my thing my thing is
I love losing so much meaning the
process the game the the going up the
hill that losing it like the way people
think I'm crazy they don't get it um I
want to weirdly lose I really want to go
back the studio apartment in Queens with
a family members because then everyone's
gonna [ __ ] on me and then I'm gonna be
like uh-huh
I'm gonna rise like a phoenix and
[ __ ] Punk all of you back in your
mouth because you [ __ ] on me like so it
so you know what I mean when people like
oh that's crazy that you said that you
must be thinking like [ __ ] do
you understand what my real life was
that that's why that's people don't get
it the biggest advantages in life are
coming up with zero right now now not
your grandfather but right now if you're
lucky enough that you know what zero
tastes like and you weren't given
anything and you're not entitled you're
[ __ ] set because the [ __ ] game is
rigged in your favor because it's open
meanwhile if you grew up super rich and
privileged and handed everything you're
finished because the institutions that
used to take care of you are losing got
it oh and you don't know how to get
yours you weren't taught to hunt you
were just fed you were fed from the get
so you have no idea how to go out and
[ __ ] hunt my man I swear to God in
life in a world where I'd [ __ ] with you
kind of characters that I [ __ ] with like
hedge fund babies I swear on my
children's health if you ask me who I
feel worse for a kid right now growing
up on the Upper East Side going to
private school who's got ten million in
the bank
or a kid in the outskirts of Atlanta or
Crenshaw I feel worse for the white kid
and I'm not or the black kid that I own
I said I said medicube but I can do
breezes eyes got a lot of money I'm like
you're gonna lose
like he's just when you're when you've
been fed especially now because when you
were fed in the 60s well you just got
fed back into a bigger machine when you
grew up and you were part of the country
club and this and that it wasn't based
on merit it was based on what your last
name was your grandfather named the
library like it was a rigged game
it's listen there's still racism there's
still sexism there's still plenty of
[ __ ] but the internet doesn't give a
[ __ ] it just is it just doesn't and
that's why things are breaking through
because even is put on and with the
streets and everything else you guys
know what happened last 20 years and
you're a guy's game yeah somebody would
break through and as soon as they broke
through they put on defense they became
the suppressor even though they looked
the part but people confused got it they
because they had financial advantages to
keeping it suppressed they would just
look at what he was doing
siphon it and then be it and pay no tax
and the streets loved them oh you [ __ ]
with us uh-huh
you're siphoning us that's the truth
that's that you know I love when people
like all white this white America's
doing this I'm like [ __ ] you
better look it is deep and it's a brain
[ __ ] and honestly I would have never
understood it had this era not come
because then I was like oh [ __ ] this is
actually what's happening
cash will grow and get to that level and
instead of sticking with the mindset as
intriguing them behind reverse a jury
that's right I want to be this is like
let me capitalize on period your needs
right
it's why we win we've been investing
this forever that you know people like
people hit me up to like oh you're
[ __ ] with hip I'm like we've been
doing this for a decade I'm like I just
have something to give now you know like
I'm here like what we did I'll be on
with him for his birthday [ __ ]
you know much more you know how much
money I put in yeah like like not for my
health
yeah we connected Jeezy with that Oh
y'all can Kenny Austin you know that's
us that's my boy that's us my guy and we
were doing a curry and that's it and
like and that's it and and honestly once
that stuff started working then I was
like [ __ ] I'm gonna build a machine
and so that's what I've been up to now
we can and back to the high/low can I
put him today with Chase banks still not
yet there's still Serena and Steph Curry
but in 48 out 48 months
it's gonna be completely Chinese I think
those around him know it is super well
gonna treat a point you're a hundred
percent right honestly that's the plug
that I think I'm gonna fit that's why
I'm spending a lot of time listening I'm
just meeting listening bringing love our
playlist just given love right it's just
respect and as soon as one domino go you
know people willing to flare up but if
you've given them no reason to they
prefer not to right they prefer not to
unfortunately if domino falls anything
we can help with from what you know
about anything anything come to mind I
really like your music to begin with I'm
accept could we will what's cool about
what I think we're doing is we're so
scaled in the entrepreneurial community
high low right like 81 to 18 that
there's we're just giving so much
exposure to artists like you're winning
you've won your thing but there's just
all this pocket of people that all they
just aren't consuming in the channels to
hear it but they're consuming me but
they still love it it's the same [ __ ]
it's just this pocket that were were we
have right now so that will definitely
do I think the more interesting part for
me though is why I wanted to have this
meeting is it's very obvious that the
ambition of the of the process is deeper
right and so to me like everybody's
young even though I'm old like
everyone's young here I'm gonna be
working for the next 40 years and I
believe in what I said about what I
started with so like to me this is like
I'm the reason I want people asking me
like why are you doing that like you
don't understand
if I give love with asking for nothing
in return for 6 7 8 years I'm thinking
about 17 years from now actually to be
very frank I'm shocked right and the
best part is honestly on a very real
kick I actually don't want to even ask
in 17 years my preference is to give it
an
never even asked for it do my thing
right so then exactly so then people are
just cheering for you right so yeah I
mean like you know back to the acting or
the writing like look we have unlimited
rolodex of relationships and
understanding and you guys have all that
too but like any work like to me it's
more just about asking like I like being
asked I prefer being asked so like we
just need to know what you know so
actually I got a question where I can
really help on the brand side the core
brand how much of it is sold
direct-to-consumer that's the [ __ ]
question all of it how is that being
sold and distributed Shopify plus
fourarms uh-huh you got a 3pl like you
do your City pack yourselves like 3pl
yep we regionally like party with a
bigger company they should support and
then we went into you know some big-box
retailers lower T shows them which ones
Jimmy's
and how are you driving
direct-to-consumer sales just as social
feel you have a [ __ ] bill in it of
course I feeling understand what they're
just all quant based dr like math kids
right
like conversion based kak LTV blah blah
blah that's not the right game that's
half the equation it's it's art and math
together making that birth child can I
give you the answer don't partner with
anybody let me help you hire some people
[Music]
don't hire don't [ __ ] par with
anybody they're in the business of
making money off you they can't it's
they're not even bad it's like the same
old psychology right it's just the way
they are they're a company they can't
try hard enough for you
cuz they have to make money too and then
the game worked and in some places it
works management management works
incentives are aligned it's a percentage
of the cut aligned not aligned when
somebody like we're not running your
media in your art against your sales cuz
they've got to make a Vig where I can
really help is that we've been doing it
for a decade I got people have left me
and are sad that they left cuz they left
for $5,000 more money and they wanted to
buy a nice bracelet now they have a
[ __ ] job and they want to come back
but I won't take them but I love them
that's the kind of people I can send to
you where would they have to live la
which day would lays the best I'm just
trying hard we have
but I would want it to be in LA - I want
them together you want to really sell
[ __ ] together I want them to sitting
like this
do you understand but you say or
pictures and the videos that make people
do [ __ ] oh you understand let me give an
example we sent you this whole video you
guys find the one minute that you like
the best the position you're the best
you run that video against fans of me on
Facebook with a call to action to buy
your [ __ ] at the end you will sell some
[ __ ] that game somebody gets it
understands it not just my song a dream
and justice but even throw
we're talking about like your honors
this is me you're hiring somebody you
listen I mean it's not rocket science
baby is no no it's honestly man it's a
skill like like right it's here's what I
would say make the investment so they're
part of the family the end
he can't rent the important [ __ ]
I'm on breath I'm all day yeah the good
thing is on that first year we built all
direct-to-consumer baby so that's our
majority of our business I figured even
with zooming I figured of course a
hundred that's where you should and like
I said earlier their stuff is like
they're doing is some of the best out of
everybody you know to change you like
there's a very small handful of people
who do merge well in hip hop and you're
one of them correct you it was faster
yeah no no actually honestly no no right
and 2 Chainz is doing like Christmas
sweaters like I'm with you I think
that's right
and chains is doing his thing but like
you know I think that's and and honestly
when people you know like this isn't
like this is an interesting thing it's
funny when you say it what went through
my mind I'm laughing because everybody
under Instagram and their profile
it says entrepreneur and I know which is
fine I can't spell for [ __ ] either saw
even gonna gas them on that my question
is that's like me saying rapper in my
profile I could I can go into it we just
build a studio in here I can go in I
could am I getting paid do people [ __ ]
with it like and that's how I'm thinking
about fashion brand like to me the
ambition of right like people like
everybody's have got a fashion brand
everybody on instagrams got a brand you
know why they took $50 they press some
[ __ ] statement on a t-shirt down the
way they post on their Instagram and
they think that [ __ ] Louis Vuitton
[Laughter]
like to build the fashion brand you all
I mean he also means that merch that's
accessible to that you know
thirteen-year-old girl
so I would say that that's right but I
do think there's a smart way to have
that conversation because where you're
at now in the beginning if you were if
if this was what do the brand come out
yeah and when did when did the music
career really start kind of like
bubbling for real right so if this was
2015 IIb I would like think in merch and
fashion brand terms right to me
at the scale that you guys are at right
now I said look Louie Vuitton sells like
$19 like it's not about the price it's
about the thought process that was
original conversation we talked about
this came to me was like yeah yeah I
just felt like March was corny at the
time like this was really out and it was
like out I mean we grew up Rockefeller
all these cats were like there let's
build a brand that we can parallel and
used the label ain't always people's
money to grow and parallel his career
uh-huh that's before they came for me
because I watch you for hundreds the
clock he grew up on us were like artists
turn four hundred into a lifestyle
forever 100 staying true to you so you
know it's not that became something that
other people don't have and I anything
you like there was a backstory to
how he got to where he is the whole you
know gives us some more substance than
just what do you guys doing in New York
Wow [ __ ] that's good that's exactly what
you should be doing that's exactly what
you should be doing in New York I just
fire fire fire the music is the [ __ ]
gateway drug period like I don't get
people you won't hear an interesting
story I met this old dude I was raising
some money for some [ __ ] back and I met
this old dude it was a weird meeting
everything else was like hedge funds and
family offices this was just like a
rogue character and I was excited cuz
I'm ro gonna like whatever you know I
was except for the meeting but we
basically didn't even talk about the
deal because quick in two seconds I
realized actually I think he was
representing Katy Perry that was him she
wanted messin stuff that I was up to but
very quickly I was like it's not gonna
be right so we're just you know having a
drink right he tells me that he was the
managers of sticks which is a big rock
band back in a day got it I was telling
about this new world there's like [ __ ]
man interesting and he's and he made a
connection a good connection
he goes do you know that sticks when MTV
came out we were one of the biggest
bands in the world and they came to us
and they said you know and people are
making their own videos that I will pay
you to make a video I think they were
doing in my favor and they were like go
[ __ ] yourself you think we're gonna make
a music video
you know that's [ __ ] music that's
free they thought in 1984 that making a
music video and if they put it on MTV
was taking away from their [ __ ] album
sales at the record store so [ __ ] you
for making me want to do video and you
got to remember
MTV is now popping every kid in America
is watching that has cable and there's
only like eight music videos on rotation
so Madonna and Prince and Michael
Jackson and everybody you [ __ ] know
in that world Durand
those are the ICONic sand the people
that had their moment Twisted Sister
Duran Duran we're all based on the
people that said yes to the video so now
I'm telling artists every day that they
come through and I'm sure you've seen
some of it or if not like [ __ ] make
music and just give it to [ __ ] like
make music as money if you got music can
you make it and get it heard give it
bloggers give it to [ __ ] nothing
would make me happier than [ __ ] some
eSports kid playing twitch rocking my
[ __ ] in the background with what a
million people watching people don't get
it musics the gateway drug like make
money on music but like that's supply
and demand like I don't give a [ __ ] if
you got the [ __ ] hottest bars there's
a trillion bars like you could be mad at
people the markets always right shows as
access will always pay for access you
need people gonna pay $100,000 to have
dinner with you in ten years that's real
people don't get it people don't
understand how to build blocks
[Music]
trying to pay a lot of money with you
right now how much you got Mike we got
to finish our negotiation so you have a
little more say it's just real man
especially if you execute yeah
but but the longer you can hold your
breath the more you're gonna get so just
keep chopping and makin keep making keep
adding victories you [ __ ] build a
billion-dollar fashion brand that opens
up some third-generation Italian family
24 year old that wants to have dinner
with you because yeah you're cool but
way more importantly you built a big
brand and hits her companies brands
getting [ __ ] up and she wants to turn
it around so how'd you actually so like
the angles people used to want to pay me
to have wine with me because I was the
wine guy until they wanted to have
dinner with me for a different reason
you know but like my business people
that [ __ ] the way I roll they're like
why do you do this why do you do this
for him and why do more importantly why
do I do it for them all my shits free
and they think that they think I'm
giving it away and I'm like you're just
confused you running a sprint and I'm
running a marathon you know that was
probably the most interesting meeting of
them all it happened so fast man I got
to tell you when we let when we finally
connected in studio yeah it was instant
we looked at each other in like five
minutes I'm like cuz you knew
I know how he thinks I'm not even mm-hmm
and he's always like trying to figure
out yeah where's the coming day so he I
knew he was looking to mentor even when
me and Liv did to hunt down I was there
yeah that was I love them too baby like
your misery
this woman yeah you talked about it just
a month in almost a year
how do we we got to make the product
worth more you know we got to make
people respect an estimate or this brand
it's like you're respected at a higher
value all you're doing is deploying
empathy to the consumer people don't get
it once they hit a certain level like
this man they start trying to take from
the consumer instead give that's all you
did it's very basic you want to figure
everything else make it phenomenal let
me give you an example
you'll sell unlimited t-shirts or or
fashion if every time I buy a fashion
thing I get a two-minute face time with
him here's the problem he doesn't have
that time so you work backwards but
that's how you do it you work backwards
people try to do the least I try to do
the most and then figure out what's real
if I could do this 97 times with every
artist that I will [ __ ] with I would I
can't so I do a little bit of lesson but
I still do it
you understand everyone trying to do the
least what's the most scale where it
could make the most money
no no if you buy a [ __ ] $30 hoodie
you come and be my homie for a year you
start with that that's not gonna work
cool next you finally land with
something that's bringing so much more
value because when you chopped it all
the way down you're still here those
[ __ ] started down here of what
they want to do for people so when they
have a meeting like this I go we'll do
something a little nice they just ended
up here we started but I'm gonna give
you my [ __ ] soul mm-hmm and then I
ended up here cuz that's real got it
Matt's
the game six I gotta go
[Music]